ministre la parole est à Monsieur Jean
Leonetti monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues la question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Premier Ministre en
prolongation de la réponse que vous
venez de donner Monsieur le Premier
Ministre j'ai moi-même comme beaucoup de
monde écouter votre discours avec
beaucoup d'intérêt hier et j'ai noté que
nous avions au moins une convergence sur
la gravité de la situation et l'urgence
que nous avions ensemble pour y répondre
cependant Edgar Morin dit à force de
sacrifier l'essentiel à l'urgence on
finit par ou l'urgence de l'essentiel or
l'Europe a très souvent très souvent
réagi aux crises réagi en urgence aux
crises et à oublier l'essentiel
l'essentiel des peuples l'essentiel des
nations c'est la raison pour laquelle ma
question porte sur deux sujets qui me
paraissent aujourd'hui essentiels le
premier c'est celui des frontières que
vous avez évoqué nous voulons des
frontières sûres et des frontières
stables vous avez laissé Monsieur le
Premier Ministre négocier Angela Merkel
avec la Turquie la gestion des
frontières et des réfugiés même si nous
devons avoir un partenariat privilégié
avec ce grand peuple dont nous
partageons aujourd'hui la peine la
Turquie ne fait pas partie de l'Europe
et nous devons l'affirmer clairement le
deuxème élément c'est l'identité
européenne oui l'identité européenne ça
veut dire que l'Europe n'est pas
uniquement un marché commercial et
financier l'Europe c'est une âme à Paris
à Berlin à Madrid ou à Bruxelles nous
avons en commun un héritage commun et
une destinée commune nous avons la même
idée de la dignité de la personne
humaine de l'ouverture à la modernité du
refus du fanatisme et de l'amour de la
liberté ces idées doivent s'incarner
s'incarner dans des grands projets qui
rejettent les normes de détail qui
encombr les
réglementations de nos entreprises pour
faire en sorte que nous donnions une
espérance à la jeunesse au travers de la
culture de l'éducation de l'innovation
du numérique et de porter enfin une
espérance
monsieur le Premier ministre depuis 4
ans vous avez déserté la scène
européenne la voix de la France doit
redevenir merci la parole
Estur
manuel monsieur le
Président Monsieur le député Jean
Leonetti monsieur le ministre vous avez
été en charge des affaires européenne en
2011 pendant plusieurs mois et vous
connaissez donc bien ces sujets et la
machine européenne pourquoi dire que il
n'y aurait qu'un seul sujet sur lequel
nous pourrions nous trouver d'accord
c'est-à-dire sur le constat c'est-à-dire
sur le fait que l'on n pas suffisamment
écouté les peuples je pourrais monsieur
Leonetti vous renvoyez aisément au
dernier quinena nous pourrions au moins
nous mettre d'accord là-dessus c'est
sous la présidence de Nicolas Sarkozi
qu'on a décidé d'adopter le traité de
Lisbonne au-delà même du référendum et
du choix du peuple Fran français en 2005
mais au-delà de ces aspects-l vous avez
traité de deux sujets le premier c'est
celui au fond de ce quelle Europe j'ai
essayé de le dire hier d'autres voix je
pense à celle de François Fillon hier
ont fait écho également à mes propos
nous sommes un
espace l'Europe c'est une culture c'est
une civilisation c'est une histoire avec
aussi son cortège de drame c'est en
Europe que sont nés les pires idéologies
au 20e siècle et qui ont conduit au
désastre qui ont fait qu'un certain
nombre d'hommes ont décidé de cette
construction européenne après la
deuxième guerre mondiale et après la
Choa donc mais nous sommes cet espace de
civilisation et un espace de
civilisation une culture avec nos
libertés avec le progrès avec l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes cet
espace de progrès il est dans des
frontières bien évidemment et ces
frontières qui peuvent nous permettre en
même temps de défendre un modèle social
cétait ça aussi l'Europe cétait ça porté
notamment par notre modèle social
français par le modèle Renant allemand
nous l'avons toujours défendu et c'est
dans un espace qui nous empêche pas de
battir de grandes alliances stratégiques
bien sûr avec la Russie avec la Turquie
avec le Proche et le Moyen-Orient avec
l'Afrique déjà pour ce qui concerne nos
voisins donc je pense que nous pouvons
nous mettre d'accord là-dessus condition
que ce modèle soit un modèle généreux
ouvert tourner résolument vers l'avenir
et c'est cette idée je crois de l'Europe
que nous pouvons défendre et nous
pouvons d'autant plus la défendre
monsieur le ministre et je l'ai dit hier
en réponse aux orateurs que il y aura un
débat en 2017 il y aura un débat sur
l'idée qu'on se fait de la France dans
l'Union européenne et sans vouloir
caricaturer le débat il y aura ceux qui
voudront que la France continue de
compter dans ce modèle européen et ceux
qui comme le Front national ou d'autres
qui sont intervenus hier qui pris par le
leur élan à des fins uniquement de
politique interne voudront que l'Europe
sorte de l'Union européenne et ça sera
l'un des clivages essentiels en 2017
l'autre sujet c'est celui des frontières
j'ai répondu tout à l'heure à Guillaume
Bachelet créons pas des débats là où il
n'y en a pas évidemment qu'il y a eu un
problème sur nos frontières européennes
avec la crise des réfugiés au-delà de ce
drame épouvantable ce qui nous oblige
aussi à mettre en œuvre pleinement notre
modèle d'asile mais bien sûr qu'il y a
eu un problème et il a fallu la force et
la combativité de la France du président
de la République et plus
particulièrement du ministre de
l'Intérieur pour que nos propositions
pour que nos propositions là parce que
s'il n'y a pas d'espace Schengen qui
fonctionne ce sont évidemment les
frontières nationales qui reviendront et
il sera fini d'une certaine manière du
modèle européen que vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure et donc les décisions qui ont
été prises au niveau européen doivent
être mises en œuvre enfin Monsieur le
Ministre pourquoi vouloir terminer
toujours par cette note négative c'est
le président de de la République qui a
fait en sorte au moment où l'Europe et
c'est d'ailleurs l'un des problèmes nous
le voyons bien nous le savons bien avec
jean-v LeDrian c'est par la voix du
président de la République par l'action
de la France que d'une certaine manière
l'Europe a pu faire en sorte que nous
sauvions le Mali quand le président de
la République a décidé cette
intervention c'est toujours par la
France et par ses armées que nous
intervenons aujourd'hui au Levant c'est
encore la voix de la France qui a permis
de faire en sorte que la Grèce reste
dans la zone euro c'est encore la voix
de la France Monsieur L
qui permet aujourd'hui oui parce qu'il
faut que les choses soient au moins
dites qu'elles soient clair et Monsieur
Jacob puisque vous étiez peu entouré
hier au moment du débat je veux rappeler
qu'ici et notamment grâce à la majorité
grâce à la gauche et grâce à des hommes
hier qui ont parler comme François
Fillon c'est une certaine idée de
l'Europe et je vous le dis très
clairement et de manière extrêmement
détendue il y en a assez de ces mises en
cause du président de la République dans
cet hémicycle il y en a assez de ceux
qui remettent en cause en permanence la
voix de la France et moi je vous le dis
soyez un peu plus fier dans ces
moments-là où tout se bouscule de ce que
fait la France et de ce qu'incarne
François
Hollande merci Monsieur le Premier
Ministre la parole est à Monsieur